[Music]
thank you
so let's start with Donald Trump who has
been indicted this week after days and
weeks of anticipation and it's supposed
to say it was something of a damp squib
I'm joined Now by Megan Kelly the
broadcaster and journalist and former
lawyer to talk about it um Megan I've
spoken to a few sort of get Trump type
people who've been determined to get
Trump for seven or eight years now and
they thought that in these 34 counts
against Donald Trump there might be
something there might be some sort of
hidden thing that would actually prove
to be quite damning but I read the
indictment uh and I think it's fair to
say that it's um comically thin with
your legal brain on would you agree I
completely agree with you and I think
they're kidding themselves I think they
should be angry at Alvin Bragg because
there may be a decent case against Trump
at least more decent than this one in
the special prosecutor Jack Smith who's
looking into whether he openly defied a
subpoena that was served upon him in
Mar-A-Lago and had his lawyer say he
turned over everything when he hadn't
that one is at least interesting it is
colorable this this one's a joke it
makes a joke out of the justice system
it's absurd to violate nearly 250 years
of precedent and not going after former
presidents criminally with this are you
kidding me it's an embarrassment and
it's obviously an attempt to fulfill a
campaign Promise by Alvin Bragg who not
wants not twice but repeatedly over a
dozen times touted his record of getting
Trump of having been part of at least
100 lawsuits against the Trump
organization and the Trump family and
Donald Trump himself and promising he
was just the man to do it if they would
put him in office by the way the people
who were persuaded by that are Trump's
jurors that's his jury pool and his
potential jury which is one of the many
reasons why at a minimum this case
should be moved out of the borough of
Manhattan which went 87 for Joe Biden
but it is thin gruel in that indictment
well there'll probably be a motion to
dismiss uh from from Trump's lawyers uh
I think the anticipation is that that
won't succeed do you think a motion to
move the the case out of New York would
succeed
I don't think the motion to change venue
will be successful but I actually don't
feel as pessimistic about the motion to
dismiss as you do
um it would take a steel spine by the
judge because you get elected to the
position he's in the judges at the trial
court level in New York get elected and
he does not want to disappoint the
electorate by saying I threw out the
case against Donald Trump so it would
take a Steely spine but eventually it
could be it could go up an appeal and I
do think a an appellate court is very
likely to say this thing ought to go not
the immediate appellate court because
they're elected as well but the level
above that because there's no there
there if you look at it just in a
nutshell what he's done is charge a
misdemeanor crime which is falsification
of business records and the only way you
elevate that to a felony which he must
do because the statute of limitations
has run on those misdemeanors it was
only two years we're five years in
um he's tried to elevate them to
felonies so we can get the five-year
statute of limitations by saying the
reason you did shenanigans on your
bookkeeping was to cover up an
underlying crime now if that's true he
does get the longer statute of
limitations but we all waited to say
what's the underlying crime tell us
we're open-minded let's see what do you
do it's Trump he did something
we don't know yesterday Alvin Bragg
tried to play pin the tail on the felony
like we have no idea I don't have to
tell you he actually said but then went
on to say maybe it's federal election
law maybe it's state election law maybe
it's state tax law well let me tell you
something Freddie it is none of those
things because there is no federal
election law violation here
um I just got done interviewing the
former head of the Federal Election
Commission under Bill Clinton okay and
this person said it's very clear under
the best argument for Alvin Bragg that
this was not a federal election law
violation even if everything Alvin Bragg
alleges is true even if Donald Trump
David pecker of the National Enquirer
and Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer sat
down and said we have three potential
stories coming out about you how can we
get rid of them let's capture and kill
them here's a slush fund to pay off
these people even if true not an
election contribution that would have to
be reported and so on it's a personal
expense was paid from Donald Trump's
personal account and it just doesn't
qualify so there's no underlying crime
look at the state law the state law
doesn't have an independent area that we
can explore the state law just says if
you conspire to cover up unlawful
activity you violated New York state
election law that now we're back to the
federal law the only alleged unlawful
activity is under the federal election
law well I just covered that for you and
the New York state tax law there was no
tax violation what they're saying is you
paid off the women then you doubled the
number you paid and you added 60 Grand
and you paid that to Michael Cohen and
called it legal expenses why did you
double the payment because you wanted
Michael Cohen to not have to pay taxes
on the fees that he used to reimburse
Stormy Daniels and the others and take
the tax at himself so the Trump
organization took the hit but New York
State didn't take a tax hit nobody
didn't get paid their taxes in fact New
York State profited off of this money
scheme that they came up with there's no
damage and there's no fraud under the
tax law and even if there were were back
to misdemeanor territory so there is no
underlying felony or crime
um and and if we're going to go down
this line you know even further and say
okay I'm wrong about all of that uh
everything I just said is untrue and
Alvin Braggs won every motion they still
have to prove that Trump knew about it
and directed it and there's a lot of
evidence that he didn't that Michael
Cohen made this up because he absolutely
hates Donald Trump and all these
meetings he had with David pecker and so
on to thank him and which didn't have
anything to do with Stormy Daniels but
had to do with the fawning coverage The
National Enquirer was doing on Donald
Trump from the get-go
well and New York state has had to pay a
lot in uh police fees and closing down
roads and so on in anticipation of uh an
upsurge of trumpist violence which
didn't materialize it does seem like a
legal nonsense and obviously a nonsense
as far as Justice is concerned should we
talk about the politics of it though
um because Trump has obviously had a
major boost in the polls as a result of
of this uh farce
Ron DeSantis is sort of a diminished
figure would you not say or slightly
knocked out the picture now and a lot of
people speculate that that's exactly
what the Democrats want and maybe this
is what it's all about it's an attempt
to make Donald Trump the nominee because
the Democrats think rightly or wrongly
that they can beat him mm-hmm careful
what you wish for uh they tried that
once before and he won in 2016. I mean
we've seen this movie before
um
earned media coverage where the media
goes wall to wall Trump and no one else
can get any Oxygen
um the the candidate himself uh you
think he's going to be under attack and
uh seen as disgusting and somebody
nobody would want anything to do with
where in fact the American people see
him as persecuted and the victim of an
overreaching left and are impressed by
his fortitude and his strength and his
unwillingness to back down
um seeing his competitors have to
scramble in their messaging As Trump
takes up all the oxygen and dominates
with yet another Scandal the messaging
that doesn't alienate his core base and
the people who love him but
distinguishes you as a different kind of
candidate no one's been able to do it at
all in 16 and 20 or today and in 16 all
these same three things were happening
and we heard this is great there's no
chance Eagan women with all this going
on and we all know what happened well
it's happening again and people don't
learn
they don't learn Trump right now is seen
as Invincible they see him defiant down
there at Mar-A-Lago saying you know I
fight for you this is about you it's not
about me with the American flags behind
him looking strong looking vibrant 76
years old but still looking very
energetic and they say he's the only one
who can fight these zealots they wanted
to pack the Supreme Court they wanted to
add extra States so they could get rid
of the filibuster in the Senate they
want open borders they want all these
they tried to absolutely demolish Brett
Kavanaugh when he was nominated to the
U.S Supreme Court with totally
scurrilous allegations you need
an extraordinary leader to take on these
fights and they don't see anybody
filling that bill besides Donald Trump
I can see yeah you're absolutely right
clearly that his his campaign has been
or his chances of winning the presidency
have been rejuvenated uh by this but is
there not a sort of longer term risk
that they're going to be more cases
we'll have the case in Georgia about
um that find me 12 000 ballots and so on
uh we'll have more about January 6th uh
and could Trump fatigue which has sort
of subsided a little bit uh in the last
few days could that come back do you
think as the sort of endless uh
allegation after allegation is is poured
out against him and people just sort of
tune off and feel fed up with I'm not
feeling that in this I mean it's
potentially true yes but the problem is
not one of these cases is sexy you know
it's not something that people can
easily connect with he had documents
that Mar-A-Lago that he is a president I
mean most of us feel like a former
president can take documents from the
White House and we're already told he
can declassify documents as the
president he says he did that with these
all right they're going to argue about
it well what's what did he really do
wrong because we know Joe Biden did it
too we know Mike Pence did it too
probably Barack Obama and others as well
what do you do you got an order to
produce them and he said he produced
everything when he had I mean it's
really hard to have your heart go a
flutter at that case it really is and
then the case in Georgia find me the
votes well if you look at the larger
conversation it's a lot more nuanced
than that he felt like he had the votes
and they were not counting them and he
was basically saying go count them for
him like I'm telling you uh this is the
number I need and they're there that's
what he's going to argue again can you
really get emotionally invested in this
one passing phrase in this much longer
conversation I don't I just don't think
people are going to connect with those
cases in any meaningful way and so they
can do 24 7 on this on CNN if they want
and people who already hate Trump will
watch it and feel gratified but I think
the Republican base which is what he
needs to get by first will be bored with
it might see that he's got baggage but
we'll also see this fighter who they
need to fight these extreme people who
don't can't even say what a woman is
um you know you need somebody who's
strong who knows how to fight battles
and craziness and I really think that it
will be more of a net benefit to Trump
than a net down inside
you mentioned Joe Biden uh it seems to
me that he's he's so far trying to act
as though he's above it uh sort of uh
his press secretary has sort of chewed
away questions about it as much as she
can uh do the Americans buy that or do
they see him as as part of the problem
that the Democrats are causing I think
he's checked out in many ways and people
understand that and he's obviously
partisan but it's yet another missed
opportunity for Joe Biden
this is a very dark day for America
yesterday whether you love Trump or hate
Trump
we've we've crossed it's a before and
moment it's a before and after a moment
for our country we there's a reason this
has never happened in nearly 250 years
and this no-name prosecutor out of New
York who's trying to become a star is
the one who decides he's going to change
all that he will Rue the day and so will
this country if you don't think the
Republicans are vindictive enough to to
turn the tables you haven't been paying
attention they will in the same way uh
they got rid of the filibuster on Lower
Court judges in the Senate and Mitch
McConnell stood up and said you will
ruin the day because you Democrats will
not only always hold control of this
chamber and when the Republicans got in
control they got rid of the filibuster
too only this time it was Supreme Court
nominees and guess what happened they
got three Supreme Court seats under
Donald Trump thanks to that the
turnabout if you don't think the
Republicans are going to turn this
around and use it against Democrats
you're crazy and if Donald Trump gets in
there you don't think he's going to
start going after people like Hillary
Clinton with his doj that's now under
his control it's it's a dark day so my
point is Joe Biden had a real moment as
the commander-in-chief as the leader of
the nation to come out and say
um this is a dark day for America the
legal process will play out as it should
and I trust in the legal process however
it is not lost on me that this is the
first in the American electorate's
history and my heart goes out to those
people who are hurting over it and I
want to reassure you that the backbone
of this country is strong and that while
we may have anomalies we may have
unusual events happen we're still strong
we still at our core love each other we
still can get past red and blue no he
didn't do it he smirked he smiled and he
declined comment it was a missed
opportunity and he looked foolish
he's actually coming to Ireland uh next
week he loves to play off his Irish
heritage you have Irish heritage am I
right insane I do I do my father was 100
Irish do you find uh Biden's Irish stick
of it bogus
well he's Irish and he's black and he's
Jewish and he's Puerto Rican I mean he's
he's claimed every Heritage Under the
Sun apart from English he never claims
that even though it's true right right
yeah so I find it a stretch
um you know here in America we've had
this round of people pretending they're
Native Americans when they're not and
they've become known as pretendians he's
that's what he's going to claim next so
I don't know hold your breath I'm not
sure about the Irish thing we'll find
out I'm sure and of course talking about
Republicans there's plenty of stuff on
the Biden family that they could go
after and they probably will
I I feel like it this guarantees it I
mean all you need is a state to
prosecutor I mean the feds aren't going
to do it because Biden controls them uh
Merrick Garland is his guy at the doj
and no federal prosecutor would do it
without his okay but the state
prosecutors I mean they're Republican
state prosecutors all over the country
including in States in which Hunter
Biden has had illegal weapons submitted
uh applications for those weapons which
appear to have had lies on them had
prostitutes had drugs on camera all
documented by the so-called laptop from
hell and that's not even to touch on his
nefarious business dealings uh and
what's gone on with the financial
alleged crimes there so the house is
investigating some of that right now
um and we'll see I he could definitely
be Target number one the clintons the
Clinton Foundation which has got all
sorts of red flags all over it uh when
it comes to their taxes and so on could
become uh the target of an investigation
down in Arkansas there could be a long
list and while it would be
further sadness for our country and what
we used to stand for it would be totally
fair
Megan it is indeed a sad day uh for
America but um it's Easter weekend
coming up so there's always hope I hope
you have a very happy Easter thank you
very much you too I'm looking forward to
it
[Music]
thank you